-NOM-
A WILD MARK HAS APPEARED
HEY! HEY! HEY! HEY! HEY! HEY! HEY! HEY! HEY! HEY!
WE are streaming right now on twitch.tv/markiplier for the Epilepsy Foundation
AND YOU'RE HERE COOKIN' A ROCK!
What are you doing? Who do you think you are?!?!
You think you're too good to have these amaving commemorative drunk minecraft mugs
available for $25 all pro-ceeds go towards the Epilepsy Foundation???
Why aren't you there!? Click on the link in description below, and you're gonna-
*Sexy Mark noises*
YA BETTER BE THERE
twitch.tv/Markiplier...
YA BETTER BEEE THEERRE
*The wild Mark has escaped*
WHAT ARE YOU STILL DOING HERE?! I DIDN'T MAKE THESE SUBTITLES FOR NOTHING! GO TO THE DESCRIPTION BELOW AND DO THE THING
*mark comes out to turn off the camera*